Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier,
And welcome to three weird games
Now, these games aren't weird because they're so unbelievably out there
they're weird because their methodology and their utilization
isn't necessarily what you would find in normal games.
The first game of which, is actually controlled
By my singing.
So you'll see that soon, but before I get started I wanted to say that
I am leaving for Amsterdam in two days.
This Wednesday I'm gonna be heading over to Amsterdam for our shows on Saturday.
So, if you haven't gotten a ticket yet, please check the link subscription below for Amsterdam tickets
if you're anywhere in the 'nair'-- in the air--
if you're anywhere in the area of Amsterdam.
So check that out, thank you everybody for watching!
and enjoy~
Okay, so this is "ONE HAND CLAPPING".
So apparently this game is controlled by your voice.
You...
(mouth sounds)  bleh bleh bleh bleh
And sing away and then it does something in the game?
I'm not a hundred percent sure how accurate that's going to be
or how well I have to sing...
if I..
if it require some sort of accuracy, I don't know if its gonna go too well...
(hah)
LA LA LA LA LA LA LA LA! Eh, No?
Nothing yet?
Hello?
Oh, shi-- aAAAhAHah...
(weird moan-singing???)
...All right. I don't know what the hell that was all about
but that happened...I'm very happy about that?
Oh?
What?
Huh?
(MARKIPLIER NOISES)
I can hear myself in the game!
Oh!
(Hits lowest note possible)
Okay, got that.
OH!
Eh..
I cou- I could hear-
LAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAUOOOO~!
HEEEEEE~! (High pitched singing noises)
See?
You see?
That's what that's about.
La la la la la la la~!
(Continues vocalizing) LEE LOO LEE LOO LOH LAI LAE
LAA!
LALALALALALALA!
LALALALALALALALAAA!
LAAAAAAAAlalaelae~.
La la la~!
(High-pitched semi-yodel)
Sorry, I'm just having fun with this one...
laLAAAAAAAlaola~
Okay,
All right, so this is the game.
its pretty- its pretty fascinating!
This, this guy is just gonna go off on all times because it's gonna...
It's gonna...
It's gonna go off, uhh, just because I was talking all the time.
But anyways, so it's like a little me in here... (Markiplier noises)
(Repeated "BLAH" sound)
(Baby sound)
I'm having too much fun with it.
Okay!
Ohh.
Wait.
(Vocalizing)
(More vocalizing)
hiYAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
(LOUD VOCALIZING)
(snorting laugh)
That's so funny.
That's so good.
That's so good!
That's funny!
That's really cool!
That works!
Okay!
All right then.
Uh oh.
Hey guys..
(beautiful Italiano vocalization)
Oh..
What am I supposed to do here?
(Continues "La La La" + Vocalization)
I wish it was like, you know, like with Bugs Bunny. Like in the orchestra, like...
You raise it higher like..
HIYAAAAAAAAA!
You know?
But, apparently nothing...
So, I don't know what they're doing about it...
(Hitting low note)
Hmm.
WELL!
I don't know about this..
Heh, just falls in-- AHH.
All right, I don't know what I'm suppose to do there.
But, we got this moaning crowd in the background and I don't know what that's all about.
So I can't get back,
Oh, I'm stuck already guys..
Apparently I'm absolutely stuck..
aAAAAAYHOOOOOOOOUOOOOAAAAAAAAIIIAIIIIIIII AYAYAYYAYAYYAYAYYAYAYAYAYAYAY
I don't know what I'm suppose to do here!
Higher pitch?
(Amazingly on-key high vocalization)
This is as high as I can go, I don't know what more..It was doing something!
(Whistles)
(Catches breath)
Okay!
All right. That's-- woof.
Okay. I think I need to re-calibrate it, because it seems to be-
(Hits low note)
Okay, that's low..
And now hopefully, it would be not require- oh!
hey, how's it..
hi-oh.. that's horrifying
ugh! its some wiggle worm gecko going on over there,
(Vocalizes low, high, then low notes)
okay!
alright
we got this!
we got it! Oh yeah!
oh! Were getting-
hmm..
tough crowd out here..
what? you don't like my singing?
HUH?
uh, oh
hello!
(Vocalizes loudly) hAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
Oh, I can stop now?
okay, alright.
this is a great vocal warm up game.
(giggling) yeah.
yeah! this game is cool!
yeah I was, I was curious on how exactly it would be. but it does- Ow, my face
excuse you.
imma just brush myself off, its all good
it's all good
oh! where am I now?
oh, no.
Will I ever see my family again?
Will I ever see?
them again?
I'm not singing anymore!
And , I don't know why.
oh, I wish- oh! there it is.
LA~!
Lalala~
I SING! to keep me~
Not, lonely!
in the
sewer~?
I'm walking through the-
(Markiplier the musical)
OH MY GOD !
ITS BEAUTIFUL!
ITS BEATIFUL~!
I OH- HEY THERE~!
(Green creature singing)
(Mimics creature) mYEHHHH! MYEEEHHHH!!
That's what I heard..
did I not get it?
(green guy makes dissapointed sound)
pff-
tough crowd, tough crowd
(Green guy sings again)
(Mark vocalizes and tries to copy him)
where is it ? I don't know.
"try singing within your range" (laughs softly)
(Vocalizes briefly)
okay! lets try!
(Mark sings as low as he can)
wait, do you really want me to go that-?
you said the lowest comfortable note I can do!
and this is bullshit
hang on.
(Vocalizes lower)
(?????) blegh blegh! blergh! blang! bling! okay
let me recalibrate again
Hhhhhoooooooooooooooooooooooo
Okay, there we go
Got the under- now were good!
Okay we got it
(Mark laughs)
Ohh whats this then?
Does it need something?
Yaalelalaloulelaaalaaaaaaaaaahhhhhhhhhooooiiii
ooh
did I not?
aaahhhhhhh
yYAAAAAH
(Mark sings until his voice's pitch reaches a maximum)
its not working..
meeEEYAAAAAAAAA
(Vocalizes low)
Ah..
(Sings)
(Sings louder)
HU- aww..
(Continues trying to sing different notes)
(singing devolves into Mark noises)
(Semi yee-haw)
it's not working
HAAAAH
HEH HOO HA
(Gibberish)
EH MOY MI HOY MI NOI
MIHOOIMINOI!
MI HOI ME NOI
(frustrated groaning)
ahh that was the one that-
that was, that was the one
ah look its shooting out music goop everywhere
aw man the world's a beautiful place
what's this then
oh boy
okay
(Vocalizes)
that's good enough for me
I'll take it
wee
ah wee
yah-whoo
uh wha-whoo (markimario is here o boi)
(Singing mark noises)
I like giving myself a challenge haha
I can't believe i can actually climb up with this
hey it works. Alright, cool
just get a nice yodel going on and we'll actually make a good platform here
(giggles softly)
(Sings and increases in volume)
that good enough? can i get over that ro - i don't think i can get over that rock
ahhh maybe maybe
c'mon ohhhhhhhh
(Groans loudly in fake frustration) (laughs)
alright. let's try this..
(Vocalizes)
Ok...seems good enough to me!
thats pretty cool
wait is there a secret path up there?
(gasp)Tell me that's a secret path, please, PLEASE tell me
Please tell me, please tell me...I want it to be nothing more than a secret path..
*mark sings in a gradual pattern up*
*goes into higher notes*
okay, let's try that now
no, AWWWW, goddammit
(Silly angry Mark noises)
didn't work
*mark gradually increases pitch*
See? It checks up in here... alright lets try this
please tell me that's a secret path...
(various 'ah's and 'ooh's)
OhhhhhHohohoho! hohohohohoho
alright, what're you?
laaaaAaAAAAAA!
what is this
wooooOOOOO...
*singing of various notes*
there we go
got it
nailed it
i am the best
i am so god damn good
thanks
thank you, thank you
this uhh, this me at my best
*le big sigh*
man I wish I was uhh
able to showcase my talent properly and not just through this asshole who doesn't know how to sing properly
oooohh
heeeeeeeeeeeeEEEEE (Sings in increasing notes)
what am i doing
(Vocalizes then voice cracks)
(Low note/sound)
(Sudden high note)
got em nailed em
laughs*
nailed it perfect
i did exactly what it wanted me to do
(Sings high then low)
ah shit
(makes silly noise)
got it
lets try that again
(High note) HEEE
(Lower note) OOOOO
(Voice cracks) OooOoOoO
ah come on
(gibberish)
there we go, got it
i think i can make this jump
Ah!
Awe
ahhh fuck
(Vocalizes) LEE LAA
EEEEH
ah to low
LEEEEEE
ah come on
(Vocalizes) LEE lo le
(Frustrated noise)
LEEEE
laaaaa
laaaa
laaa
LEEEEE
got it nailed it
nailed it
am i blowing out everybody's ears
am i absolutely blowing out everybody's ears with this
i probably am
(laughs)
If i did sound of music
something like that
(Green creature sings)
(Mark mimics creature) La la la LA!
perfect
this is the greatest game that ever existed
this is the best
(laughs)
alright, i'll try to keep it a little farther away
i'll try to keep it a little farther away
but not much farther away
just a little bit
just uh
kiss*
spicy little bit
(Vocalizes)
nice
got it
i got it
your ears are bleeding but that's ok
that's ok
i got this
don't worry about a thing
just fell out of your chair, your belly hurts
what is this funny to you
is my singing funny to you?!
(sings)
(snorts in laughter)
I can hear myself
its just a "muhaaaa"
(sings)
(sings longer)
(higher note)
nice
(laughs)
that's so cool
its just a unique concept for a game
(sings)
(tries again)
(slightly higher note)
(can hear echo of marks singing in background)
(Even higher note)
(echo continues)
that's so weird
that's so weird!
(sings)
(lower note)
*listens to echo*
(even lower note)
(laughs softly at echo)
that's so cool
that's so cool!
(high note)
(lower note)
oh
(even lower note)
(tries over and over for the note)
(laughs)
it so cool cause you can hear yourself
it actually records your voice in the game
(sings)
(higher note)
(even higher note)
oop
(lower note)
(higher note)
ah weird
that's so weird
its like..this is actually trying to teach you how to sing
because, what that was, it was trying to help you find intervals
and that last one
(green creature sings)
(mimics creatures song)
its like this game is teaching you how to sing
this game is
this game is teaching you how to sing!
that's what its doing, or at least is a rudimentary thing in it, but its teaching you to sing
that's so cool!
(sings)
(High then low note)
(high note)
got it
divide by my voice and you will get beautiful music
ah
also whos this guy
or girl
or whatever
(green creature sings)
(copies creature)
wow
we are literally gods
who can make things with our voices
(creature sings)
(Mark mimics creatures song)
perfect
(creature sings)
(Mark sings)
nice
very nice
"Penis Man"? (laughs)
you can't just name everything a penis!
(Penis man sings)
(Mark sings)
nice I nailed it
I nailed that
I nailed that!
hell yeah
Lalala!
(creature sings)
huh
(Mark sings)
nice
ah man
this, this is really cool
like as much as i'm joking around this is legitimately cool
they've done a good job with this
making something special
(Creature sings)
(Mark sings)
nice
says the guy, okay listen
I
whens the last time i named something a penis
it was you guys that named that lake a penis, this is not a penis man
you don't know ,  oh that's probably not good
look out the suns looking at you
(Penis man sings at the sun)
are you going to blowup the sun
(Penis man continues singing at the sun)
you better not blowup the sun
(Mark copies Penis Man) Lalalala!
its not a penis beam!
(Penis man sings at sun)
he built a city
(Penis man continues singing)
(Mark does his best to copy the song)
(Penis man sings again)
(Mark tries to copy the Penis Mans song)
is that close enough
is that pretty good
la he ha HAAAAA
its  my song!
i like penis!
are they going to record that or is that, is that like
is that, can i have a do over on that song i don't think i really
ohh shit
i wasn't really ready so if you could like give me uh
if i could get a do
if you, let me have a do over
(clears throat)
(Makes loud gibberish noises)
(laughs)
that's so cool
that was really cool
they did a great job with this one
this is,  this is something special
this is something special
like me, like i'm not a great singer
like uh, especially when i'm doing a lets play but
if you where trying to build some sorta like, i kinda want to try it
like, it's the first game i've seen that walks you through it so beautifully
that's so, that's, that's such a cool game
that's such a cool game
that was so cool
i was hoping that it would take the sample that i played and like make it into the credits song
like just insert it some how with some algorithm and just make it into that
but that was so cool
this ones called Pet the Pup at the Party
how to play
your at a house party you do not know anybody
but legend tells of a very good puppo hiding somewhere in this house
the clock is ticking and you're running
of course i'm running
it's a party where I don't know anybody, I literally walked into someones house then I started to sprint as fast as I could towards the puppo
aggressive hmm*
clink*
lets do this
I'ma pet that puppy
I'ma pet that, i'ma pet the shit out of that puppy
wow, hey, um
find that pup
hey, hows it going
do you like Russian accent
how about a french you like
you like a french accent
how about you dude
you like whatever accent this is
maa
I'm squidward
yeah that's pretty much exactly that
okay
hello
hi
excuse me
sorry
sorry sorry
wheres that puppy
I heard pray tale that they was a puppy around here
hey have you seen a puppy
sorry
poppy
ooh
i heard that
wait
I heard a puppy
I heard it
why does this bathroom lead..
how big is this house?
I hear a puppy
I hear it
puppy
excuse me
sorry
hup
how
oOoOooOOoOo
ho
oh wow
alright where's that pup I heard that pup
i heard that pup
so its a limited amount of time, i only get so much time per pup
oh that's pretty cool
k pup
oh oh
oh
I saw that arf i don't know if that arf is misleading me or if that's a real arf
arf?
arf again!
mar
marco
arfo
polo
this is whatthewhatthe what are you doing in here alone
why you smoking in the bathroom
this doesn't make any sense
oh god damn it it put me a long, wrong way
oh no wheres that puppo
hello
did I come through here
I can't remember
hello
I heard there was a puppo
hello I can't hear it anymore
ahhhh
how do I get over there
puppo
theres puppo
bed
puppo
no
arf arf
puppo
ohhhhhh
oh that's a good one
that is a
Gizmo
aww that's so sweet
aww
alright I think I heard it generally over here
puppo
hello
is there another door in this bathroom
maybe
hello
sorry
ahh god damn it oh no
oh no I met a, I went a fundamentally wrong way
big gasp*
never mind I went the right way, I was miss hearding
oh
hey
pup pup
PUP
OoOoOooOOOo
look at em
Daisy
ohhh i'm going to find that pup
i'm gonna find that pup
uh oh no pup there
oh no
pup
no pup there
hello
i heard that
far away
ok so i got a long way to go
i'm gonna find this pup
i'ma find this pup
hello pup
pup
where was that
*someone new is taking over the subtitles now, yay!!*
*weird sounds*
This is a dead end! *No idea what's going on*
What is this weird house?
What kind of creepy party is this?
What are you people?
Where'd you all come from?
And why am I here and I don't know anybody?
There are so many people in this place
and I still don't know anybody?
Oh God damn it, oh no
Oh! *Inhalation from Markimoo* There! There!
Maybe it should be the first move is just looking around for where the arfs are coming from
but maybe the arfs don't show up until you get a certain distance
to it.
Because that could be entirely possible. *arf*
Wait!
*Bunch of continuous waits and woah's*
*sharp inhalation*
Hey! Hello.
Michi! Go on Michi.
Where? Where? Find that pup.
Ok. I'll bet you that he's there.
Ok.
I'mma be out of time before I find this pup!
Pup! Excuse me, pardon me!
I need to get a puppy! *Chica*
I need to find one and I'm going to steal it.
I'm literally here to steal your dog.
Who's evers house this is ours-
I'm going to steal-
I was just shouting as loud as i can, i am going to steal the dog that is at this party.
I hope that someone doesn't stop me from stealing the dog!
Cus that is my only objective here.
Ooh i am literally-
Hooow
Where do i go? I dont know-
i - I've been here.
Hello? Oh boy
Oh no, no no
Please, somebody help me find this dog! It is super important that i find-
There is no dog- There's no doors- There is no dog.
It's uhh fundamental flaw in the layout of this house.
There is nothing, i wish i could find-
Hello? Anybody? Okay.
Alright- dis, wait, no, secret door?
(Big gasp)
Secret door. You thought you could hide from me-
Pup- Please, i wish i could sprint!
I mean i'm already running, and obviously i don't get a lot of exercise.
Please- pup please.
No! Where? behind me?
No!
Pup!
Please! Oooh
Ooh
(Sad silence)
Okay, well that sounds pretty good.
I talked to- i explored 69 rooooms
I explored 69 roooms
That pretty good, but that's kinda of a one and done, unless theres like- oooh
huwa-
There's 52 puppos?
There's 52 puppos?!
There's fifty-
Fifty-freaking-two puppos.
There are fifty- ooh my god
Alright lets go again.
I wanna go again, i want to find this dog.
Now that i know what i'm doing, now that i know.
Instantly go- i saw that arf.
I saw that arf. Well this is a bad start.
I saw the arf.
It's on the other side.
It's somewhere wrapped around.
Excuse me, pa- oh god im already off to a bad start.
Hey how's i going? Hello, hi, hello.
Nice guitar.
Hello, hi, hi
you du here to do yoga?
What you doing here for?
Oh hello, hello?
Nope, nothing here.
(blows)
Hello? I heard that.
You can't run from me.
You can't r- there!
Oh! Look at that one! Look at that one!
Mistu!
(in the distance) Arf Arf!
Oh wait, that sounded close.
That- aah shit, i always go into a closet first, just to test myself.
Ooh boy, ooh boy
Ah this is always going to be a dead end.
(soft) okay.
I don't know where [the barking] is. I can't tell, i have no idea.
Hello? Anyone seen a pup? Okay heres the bowl for the pup, where's the pup?
I don't see a pup. I went the wrong way, fundamentally.
Damnit.
Dooh It's over there, how do i get over there though?
How do i- that doesn't make any sence, how did i get to this closet?
There's a- how'da there was no more doors.
the- i mean- (mumbles)
aaAh
How did i miss this? hoh, oh my god, dog please, please dog.
Please, help, please
Help me, get out of my way.
Hello, dog, hello- yees! Oh look at this one!
That's a good one.
Daaave, you look like a Dave.
Oh my god, aah i heard that.
Where that puppo go?
Where's that puppo? Where's that puppo?
Where you are? Where you at, where you at puppo?
Heh?
Where you at?
Oh, wait- over there! I saw it. Okay.
I'm locked on target.
Where? Where you at?
Where- come on, i've got to be getting close.
Come on, i know I'm close. I know I'm close.
(Gasp) Yes, oh record time for doggo.
Record doggo.
Record dog- get- yes!
Oh yes!
You look l- Penelope?!
Oh, you are a beautiful girl!
Ooohoh
Where? I heard that, okay, i'm gonna find that pup.
This game is best game ( x 3 )
By the way, best game. Best game ever made.
Best game ever made, easily.
100% best game-
Arf? Okay, i see ya, i see ya, i see ya, I've got three dogs in my arms and i can't put anything intell i- okay well oh well shit.
Um, alright, well i uh-du its right there.
Oh It's right there, but how do i- dUoh its right there!
But how do i get there? Wait-
No, don't do this, to mee.
There's gotta be like, secret bathroom door?
It's right there!
It's right on the other side of this...
How do I get over there?
OH GOD DAMN IT!
OH GOD DAMN IT! D:
Oh DAMN IIIIT!
Oh no, oh n- oh no
Where can I get my hacks so I can just note clip through the walls and be able to get straight to the dog :(
Hello, Hi. Yes I know...
DAH-I know I'm incredibly cool.
Ugh
Dog.
dog.
dog?
Dog?
HUAAGH (Mark Inhales)
DA-Oh my god, that's a cute one :3
Cosmo-oOOoo :D
OH GOD WHY? Every time I go into a closet immediately.
The first thing I go to every time is a god damn closet.
ok
Alright. This way?
Hello.
Hi.
I also like how I'm running, straight sprinting with my hand jutting out in front of me.
Like- The most threatening thing I could do in a room full of other people is just like-
HUAGH - HUAGH (mark exhaling)
Breathing heavily sprinting through, knocking over chairs with my hand stretched outwards.
Ooooo...
OOO-YEAH!
HUAGH! (Mark inhaling... again)
Look at you! :3
Oh y- HARIBO! You sit so good! :D
Oh you sit so good!
You sit so good- Im going for world record. Uuh- Pup pets by the way.
I-Im gonna get all of them in this one game, I'm never gonna stop.
Hallo.
Hi.
Hello- Hello
Hi. I don't care.
Hello. I-I could not literally care less.
I don't care. You are human and therefore irrelevant to this, entire organisation.
Hallo?
arfs?
Huaaagh (Mark inhales again)
We're getting close! :D
O- SHET.
ARG- BBRRR Eeeii?
(Weird mark noises)
Yes?
wait.
We were close...
Wait right there! Right there!
Right there! Right there!
noo. Noo! NOO!!
How can you talk with pizza in your mouth? I don't even understand! D:
Hallo.
Hello.
Here?!
Sec- Secret? GAUGH!
Where'd you go? :(
What the hell?!
No!
I was right- GAUGH! Did I go the wrong way?
AWW!
But it was totally worth it! :3
On the pool table like a- Cleo!
Like a good- Like a star!
Way over there. Ok. So I'm guessing its gonna be like a wrap around from the other side.
I have no reason to guess that...
But its gonna be over this way.
I need to make a right eventually.
Alright, here we go.
oouUAGH- Yeah this is gonna be...
(Wispers) Its gonna be a right to it.
yep.
u-huh.
Ok there's a dog bed.
Dog? HUAGH (Mark inhales)
AWW! :3
O mah gawd. Th- This look like Chica! :D
MAEBY? Maybe cute! :3
(Whispers) Definitely cute! <3
Definitely 100% cute.
Aw man, that was a good one.
Aw man, there's the closet again.
Hello.
Hi.
How are you?
How you doing?
Good? I don't care.
Literally don't talk to me, just shut up. Everybody literally just- Pf-eh- Fall down a well.
I- I literally couldn't care.
There's a dog,
and I need to pet it. :3
I absolutely have to pet this dog.
No matter what I do, I have to pet this dog.
'Scuse me.
Pardon me.
Sorry!
Pardon me! Get out of my way!
Alright. Hello.
Hi.
Nice SHET!
I dont know what kind of person lives in this mansion but they're probably a stuck-up asshole.
But...
That was close...
That was VERY close.
Where was that??
Where was that?!
Where?
GUAGH! :(
Where Was That?!
That was someplace nearby!
Oh no..
o-oh-Oh no...
Oh no.
No. :(
No not like this! Not like this!
What is this? A BROKEN? IS THAT A DOOR? IS THAT SUPPOSED TO BE A DOOR?
Oh no :regret:
Not like this. Please.
HUAGH (Mark inhales)
SECRET DOOR!
YESSSSS!
MAGIE! YOU LOOK LIKE MAGIE! :3
O MAH GAWD! You're so cute!
FLORENCE! <3
I dont think it matters which way you go because...
I believe there is only like probably one generated path to..
like the destination right?
It would'nt just..
It wouldn't just lead you around in circles right?..
Am I going the right way or the wrong way...
Hello?
Closet. :T
OH- no.
Oh- Im going the wrong way! :/
Oh gawd DAMN IT! >:(
Oh no..
No please!
No! Not like this! :(
No! Not when theres one more bit!
I bet its gonna be a really cute one too! D:
I bet its the cutest one I've ever seen! D:
Hello!
Hi.
Oh no..
Oh no...
This way?
I don't know!
Arf for me!
Arf one more time!
Please?
HUAGH! (Mark inhales)
OOH!
9!
8!
OH MAH GAWD! D:
OH MY GOD!
Please!
Please.
please.
Pup- YES YES YES YES! :D
(Mark slowly dying from heart attack)
That was a good one. Tar- TAR! :3
That was so worth it!
I don't think im gonna get another one.
Unless I get like laser-focused into the exact right place that I need to go to be able to get this one pup. :(
Ah-
HUAGH (Mark inhales again)
Thats very close.
Thats really-
Thats really close.
HUAGH! OH!
(Mark dies from cuteness)
Yes. :3
Mulder! :)
Yes!
Yes.
Yes! This is the greatest day of my life! :D
This is the greatest day of my life!
This is the greatest day of my entire existence! :3
Oh-
Man.
Oo- I heard that!
I dunno where.
GET OUT OF MY WAY NED! D:<
Jesus!
ok.
Escuse me.
hallo?
hello.
OOH- Yea!
Secret door!
I love those secret bathroom doors.
ok.
oh.
There it is.
Uhh- through here?
yea.
Is it in here?
no.
No no no no..
yea.
Yea.
Yea?
Where?
Ya- It was here! I heard it!
y-
Ooh!
HUAGH! EEE!!
Eee!
Hey Callie! :3
Hi Callie.
I got eleven. I think im getting the record on this one.
I think im doing real good.
ok.
No secret door.
Its gonna be down to the wire on this one!
I dunno if im gonna ma- Oh SHET! Im definitely not gonna make it. Not now.
Oh no.
The worst thing that could ever happen to me is if I see it in sight-
and I dont have enough time to get to it. :(
Thats gonna crush my entire soul. D:
I am never gonna forgive myself.
If that happens.
oh no.
Oh no oh no oh no.
Oh no.
No-
oh no.
Oh no.
oh no. :(
wait-I heard that!
No- Please! Please!
Im probably close!
I-i-im probably definitely very close!
Please.
Ned!
GET OUT OF THE WAY! D:
No.
No!
NO!
NOT LIKE THIS!
NOT LIKE THIS- DAMN YOU NED!!!
DAMN YOU!
Haugh.. (Exhale of disappointment)
oh.
But thats ok.
I listened to 20 episodes of my favourite podcast?
Hell yeah!
Hell yeah.
hah.
Well I did it! That was fun. That was pretty good. That was pretty good.
Lemme go back to- uh- I wanna look at all the-
All the various puppos.
Awwwww :3
The good dog gallery!
Aw thats good. Aw we got some good ones!
Aw we got some good ones! Yea.
Oh we definitely got some good ones. :3
Dats pretty cute! Dats pretty- OH!
Oh you can- OH MAH GAWD! (Mark overloads with cuteness)
Theres bios! For all of them!
Callie, Spaniel mix, Loves to spoon in the AM. Littles spoon only? :3
OH! (Cuteness overload)
Oh my god!
Italian greyhound. Just a fragile littles doggo draped in velvet!?
(Mark dies of cuteness again)
Oh my god! Fluffy Dachshund.
Named after the iconic Florence welsh. Literal diva. :3
Oh my god! I bet she is!!
#davethewheaten. Smash that like button! (Laughs)
SMASH That like button! SMASH IT!
Pembroke welsh corgi. Appears cute. May actually be the devil? (Laughs of cuteness)
Papihuahua. Good boy?: Oh heck yeah most definitely.
Gracie. Pembroke Welsh corgi. A bouncy little bundle of love and kisses and-
SPLOOTS! :3
(Mark slowly dying of cuteness)
Im going to DIE!
(Weird mark noise)
I love these god damn dogs!
Gizmo. Pugairn. Loves cheese. Does not love halloween. (Laughs)
Glen of Imaal Terrier. Part pupper, mostly a scruffy gummy bear.
ooh- my god! :3
Maeby. Yellow lab. Likes: eating, sleeping, sitting like a proper lady! :D
Maeby the lady!!
Oh my god im gonna die!
Shiba Inu. Spins in circles and bites her fluffy tail when excited.
I DO TOO! :D
Husky. Knows how to open doors. Mischievous mastermind. AW!
Michi is so smart!
Michi the mastermind.
Mulder. Dachshund. Trots along side you during walks.
Wants to believe!?
(Mark dies of cuteness again)
I both don't know what that means and absolutely know what that means!
Wants to believe?
Wants to believe?! :3
Penelope. Boxer. Loves squeaky tennis balls. Hates flip flops!! (Laughs)
And Tar. Black lab. Sweet soft boy. Misses his home planet?!
OH!
Nooo...
AAARGH! (Dies)
Ok. That was pet the pup at the party.
(Dies again)
Im glad I played it again. Im glad I played it again. Im glad I played it again.
UUuuhh..
Hallo.
Ok. So this is-
(Music starts and stops)
Holy shit. My ears!
Ok!
Welcome to: Check please!
Uh..
I dont like how the way my hand is undulating right now. But this is a physics based-
Dating simulator.
"Why does that girl have a mustache?"
Why? You got a problem with girls with mustaches?
Why? You being judgmental over there?
That's not very nice. That's not very nice at all
Oh and now she doesn't because she was self conscious and she shaved because you-
You-
You were judgy
You were judgy about it
Shame
Shame for that
Judging someone on their appearances, that's shame.
That's a straight up shame
Can't believe you did that
Alright
Why doesn't it stay rotated?
Why's- Why is rotation o-only temporary?
Okay...
Alright hang on I got it..
How do I...
Woah
Ah
Uh huh...